hi awesome to see you great to see a
packed room my apologies for people in
the front you're gonna have like neck
pain at the end of this talk from
watching up and the people at the back
well I'm not sure about Heights but it
seems pretty crazy to be up there all
right we're gonna talk about
well a lot 2.0 or 2.1 I'm gonna start by
asking you a question if I stand back
here by the way I can see you without
the lights in my eyes so uh who ears
using or 2.0
show hands like almost everybody kind of
makes sense if you're here who's using
OA 2.1
like nobody's like what the hell are you
talking about what's oh at 2.1 well
that's why you're here I'm kind of
guessing and I'm gonna talk about
um oi 2.0 today but before you try start
throwing things at me hear me out I'm
not gonna mess up your time I'm gonna be
speaking about oauth 2.0 security best
practices or best practices in general
and the story goes as follows this is
from 2012 the original oad specification
built in a completely different time
2012 is 10 years ago that's actually
October 2012 so it's almost
um on the dot like a couple of days
missing but this is literally from a
decade ago and you can imagine a decade
ago web applications looked quite
different and today
web applications have evolved and we've
learned a lot about how attackers
operate and what may have not been the
best choices back in 2012 or that they
haven't preserved their benefits today
and things have changed over time and
over time we've gotten all these
additions to the oad specification there
have been addendums and security best
practices and oh yeah mobile apps
probably do something special as well
and for front-end web apps we kind of
have separate rules and all of them all
of a sudden we have this whole Suite of
specifications and if you are a new
developer if you're trying to get into
oauth today it's a mess basically you
start with a spec from 2012 and you read
it and you're like okay
I probably did not really get that but
sure let's let's continue and you're
gonna dive into the other specs and it's
like oh but this spec says that that is
no longer valid from the original spec
and in essence you have this whole messy
ecosystem and you need to read about
five six specifications to get a current
idea of what you're supposed to do today
and even then it's not that clear and
that's something that a lot of people
struggle with so what happened is
that the working group decided like yeah
this is probably not the best way of
doing things and the old spec is kind of
not great anymore so let's build a new
one well not a new one but let's
consolidate current best practices in
oau 2.1 so let's just take the original
spec remove everything that is
deprecated they shouldn't be doing
anymore add in everything that we
learned in the meantime like yeah this
is something you should be doing and
start adding it on top of that and that
became all out 2.1
and or 2.1 does not exist yet so this
stock I'm going to keep having having to
update this over time because this is a
draft document as in this active ongoing
work and the direction of where it's
going is fairly clear fairly
straightforward which is why I am
talking about it but in the end the
draft is not finished yet there might be
some changes along the way but I'll keep
updating this session as I give it uh in
other occasions so that's essentially
the setup for today what am I going to
talk about I'm going to talk about oat
best practices I'm going to talk about
some things that do change in 2.1 and by
the end of this session you'll have a
definitely a good idea of what you're
supposed to be doing today which are oi
2.0 best practices and if you're doing
that you'll be ready for oauth 2.1 when
it comes out
now there's a side note here it also
means that new features that have been
added that are really really great
aren't really backboarded To Oi 2.1
because the the people behind the spec
want to preserve some form of backwards
compatibility as in they don't want to
start forcing you if you're doing
current best practices today that you
also have to do this and this and this
and this even though
um you probably want to uh they're not
going to enforce that so oau 2.1 will
live together with additional expansions
that further improve the security of oat
flows if you prefer to all right that's
a short introduction so what are we not
going to talk about we're not going to
talk about open ID connect so open ID
connect is about user authentication so
whenever you end up on the website I'm
going to use zoom as an example because
well since about two years everybody in
the world knows and uses Zoom whether
you like it or not so why not so when
you arrive at Zoom you're going to have
the authentication dialog which is oidc
you have like Federation at the bottom
social login Enterprise login all of
that stuff is open ID connect it's built
on top of ovad it uses the same Concepts
as oad but I'm not gonna dive into the
details of that so if you want to
represent this schematically what we
have here is we have a bunch of clients
asking for user authentication that's
open ID connect and that is out of scope
so forget about open ID connect we
mentioned it um and we don't have to do
it for the rest of this session
what are we going to talk about we are
going to talk about oauth comes into
play when again Zoom if you schedule a
meeting on Zoom you can say like add
this to my Google Calendar account and
zoom is going to take the user to Google
ask well Google is going to ask like are
you sure you want that do you want to
give Zoom permission to your calendar
yes or no and I talked about this in a
workshop before and a lot of people were
like uh no I don't and they would click
the cancel dialect but that's a lot
essentially main use case of oat asking
access on behalf of user Zoom asking
Google I would like to access the
calendar API on behalf of who the user
is Philip in this case which Zoom
doesn't have to know and that's all out
can I access the API the question to the
authorization server that's a client
asking access using an access token to
contact apis to make API calls and then
we have the apis making decisions used
on based on these access tokens with
very implicit relationships or explicit
relationships with the authorization
server that's a lot
and that's essentially going to be the
focus for this session here today we're
going to talk about best practices that
you should be doing some limitations
also in the old specs and some guidance
on how to improve that further
all right with that out of the way let
me quickly introduce myself I'm Philip
Drake I'm from Belgium and I've been at
NDC of the various NDC conferences for a
couple of years now and it's absolutely
awesome and it's great to see so many of
you back here today my main thing is I
run my own company called pragmatic web
security and I help developers build
more secure software only mainly through
training and Conference workshops like
in Hunt in-house training conference
workshops and security API security
Frontline Security oidc topics like that
and also through like highly specialized
Consulting on difficult security topics
I'm a Google developer expert and an
alzero ambassador which are kind of
Outreach recognitions from these
companies so I don't work for Google or
at xero they just
um like what I'm doing and they want to
send me free t-shirts every now and then
if I mention that I'm a Google developer
expert or an outdoor Ambassador so
that's that's a relationship there and I
also organized something in Belgium
called Sega death a week-long course on
security if you're interested in that
check it out
um online
but enough about me let's talk about
oauth so what's there in or 2.0 or 2.1
well let's start with the flow that
makes things fairly easy let's start
with a client credentials flow so what
are we doing here we're basically trying
to access an API I'm going to use a
restaurant review app as my training
application called restograde why
because I like food I like good
restaurants and well this kind of mixes
security with my my hobby which is nice
food so um that kind of makes sense
restaurant review app everybody knows
how that works easy conceptually and in
this case we have a client application
trying to access some information on
that restaurant review API directly that
client application wants to get a list
of or statistics from the application
like how many reviews have been created
yesterday across how many restaurants so
that the client can use that for God
knows what reason this is essentially
direct access to an API as a client
application it's not really on behalf of
a user it's just like hey give me
something from a non-public API from
Point as we need some authorization in
place to access that endpoint
all right this service here that we have
at the bottom that is your oauth client
application and to get started you have
to register that client that's kind of a
requirement in oauth well actually the
specs as you can also do it in different
ways but we're not going to talk about
that literally in the spec like that's
your problem not ours but in this case
the client will be registered meaning
the client has an identifier in the
oauth ecosystem and probably also has
credentials or some Secrets can be key
based authentication can be client ID
client secret much like a password
doesn't matter much what you're using or
2.1 supports various mechanisms
all right apis are also typically
defined at the authorization server so
there's some notion of what an API is
how that exactly works very much depends
on your implementation so for example
alt zero is going to use like very
specific identifiers for apis other
systems are much more implicit about
that use a mechanism like Scopes to
differentiate between apis but that
doesn't matter too much for what we're
going to talk about here
all right so once we have our client we
have an API we can ask for an access
token so how does that work well the
client goes to the authorization server
using client credentials and says like
hey I'm this client here's my client ID
and secret or here's something I signed
to show you that I'm the real client can
I get an access token for the API please
authorization server verifies that comes
back to yeah here's an access token and
the client can now access that API with
the access token this is the client
credential slow as we've always known it
and that's still a current best practice
that is a flow that has survived from
that original 2012 spec up to today and
it's used quite often for machine to
machine access API to API communication
and so on so this is a quite common
pattern and an integral part of the
oauth spec
all right
I know most of you are Developers
so if you look at pretty PowerPoint
slides you get kind of angry you want to
see monospace funds so here you go a
requests like this would look as follows
we have a call to the Token endpoint
um on the authorization server we have a
grand type client credentials just as
before we have the client exchanging
um
a client ID here we have the client
authentication properties the client
secret and we have in this case an
audience that's an r0 specific thing
because this is a request from My Demo
scenario without zero I use that for my
trainings
best practice client credentials Grant
from machine to machine access that's
one of the first takeaways for this
session that one is still today a
current best practice that's something
that you definitely want to use in your
oauth architecture all right still
present in the oauth 2.1 spec as well
good step number one what else do we
have well most use cases rely on some
user-based access a client accessing a
resource on behalf of a user for that
use case we still have our restaurant
review application on the right and we
now have a client that allows you to
schedule reviews I'm going to use
somebody from the audience as an example
like you here up front you seem like you
enjoy good restaurants right and you
kind of look like an influencer so you
might want to be like I want to post my
reviews at the best optimal time not at
9am in the morning because nobody cares
about going to a restaurant at 9am
they're still dealing with the alcohol
from the night before when you went out
so but about 5 p.m in the evening that's
that's a perfect time so you want to use
a tool like this to schedule your review
so they come out at 5 PM perfect time
everybody starts looking like where are
we going to eat tonight like oh that's a
great place and that's how you optimize
your
influence basically I do the same for
scheduling tweets about slides and
conference talks so I don't live to eat
that often in this case it's an
application trying to act on behalf of a
user it's an application that will go to
the API at some point in time and say
like hey I want to post this review in
the name of this particular user user
based access
how do we set that up well again you
register that client application it's a
backend web app in this case a backend
web app you register that with your
authorization server and when you do
that you'll have to enter a couple of
interesting values such as a redirect
URI the Callback you have to specify
when
my interaction which I'll show you in a
second my interaction is done I expect a
callback at this particular endpoint
meaning that you'll get a requested at
endpoint you get some information and
authorization code which we'll talk
about in a second at that end point you
can use that to continue the flow with
specific steps and you have to register
that value up front for security
purposes otherwise an attacker could
come in and be like when you're done
just send it to evil.com and uh you're
you're good with that and that's not
possible because of this registration
step
now this is where
or 2.1 kicks in as in all out 2.0 was
like yeah you have to register this
um redirect your eye it's important but
you're you're kind of free to do that
however you want and a lot of people
started using wild cards or partial
matching and stuff like that
which resulted in potential security
bypasses and that's essentially why they
said in or 2.1 and in oauth 2.0 security
best practices like yeah let's not do
that anymore we use exact URI matching
for the Callback like if you want
multiple you can have multiple you can
provide a list of callbacks but it has
to be an exact match not a partial match
not a wild card these things should not
be used anymore these days all right
that's the setup once our client is
configured how do we progress well we
run a flow and that's where things get
what's the word um more difficult
because the user is involved but the the
correct term would be interesting that's
where things get interesting because now
we involve a browser of the user right
so the user starts some interaction with
that application connects to my
restaurant review application connect to
that account so you have option the
option to post a review in my name and
the uh the the flow starts so the
backend application initiates a flow
which will basically redirect the
browser of the user to the authorization
server and that's where a lot of messy
Parts come in and the URL to do that
looks exactly like the one you see here
or that's one example of what it looks
like it's a redirect including all the
information about how the flow should be
run for example online line number two
you get a response side what do we
expect as a response a code an
authorization code and who are we we are
this particular client the the scheduler
client that is trying to get a token and
when you're done you should send that
authorization code as a response to this
URL the Callback that's the URL that has
been registered up front and it has to
be an exact match when this is executed
that's step number two the browser is
very obedient the browse is like oh
redirect I'm gonna follow that and the
browser will go to that authorization
server
now if the browser has an active session
this is where the browser would send a
cookie along with that request and the
authorization server would know who you
are it's like oh yeah this is Philip
from 10 minutes ago fine and you don't
have to authenticate if there's no
active session then there will be
authentication on that step the
authorization server will be like who
who are you and what are you trying to
do and that's an authorization step
there's optional consent as well like
are you sure you want to give this
application access to that API on your
behalf like Zoom asked or Google asked
for Zoom something like that that's
essentially what happens in that user
interaction
if you've been using oauth you're
probably familiar with that step as well
when that is done we get the
authorization code as a response which
is returned to that callback URI back
with a redirect through the browser and
it ends up on that backend application
which now gets an invocation a get
request it can retrieve that
authorization code from the URL that one
is listed right here you see how that
works the Callback is called the listed
callback from before with that
authorization code that can be extracted
from the URL
and now ends up on the backend
application so what I'll do next
let me do a code exchange we have to
exchange that authorization code for
tokens with the authorization server so
our application our scheduling app goes
back to the authorization server server
to server communication and it's like
yeah I would like to exchange this code
for tokens so I can actually do
something useful on behalf of the user
that step requires Authentication it's a
backend app that step is protected with
authentication to avoid abuse in case
somebody intercepts that authorization
code one way or another very important a
security property here in this flow
request looks like this it's again to
the Token endpoint we are exchanging an
authorization code we are this
particular client he we receive the code
on this particular URL and here's that
code that we received
fairly straightforward standard a lot
stuff and if everything checks out the
authorization server will give you that
response here's the response with an
access token and a refresh token and now
that scheduling client can access the
API on your behalf both that review that
you wanted to post and take it there
that's essentially how the authorization
code flow works
the authorization code flow from 2012.
the authorization got flow from 2012
that is no longer valid today in that
form as in or 2.1 says like every
authorization code flow today requires
the use of pixie
which brings us to the question what is
Pixie
or something more explicit that I'm not
going to say out loud here but what is
pixie pixie means proof key for code
exchange
which of course prompts the response
like ah
what that's a very complicated name for
what pixie actually is and the goal of
Pixie I'm going to explain that next
because it is a best practice today the
goal of Pixie is to tie the start of a
flow the initialization of a flow
to the exchange of the code to avoid
somebody messing with the Integrity of
those steps to ensure that these steps
happen in the correct context and that
they are associated together and we're
going to do that using a hash function
and here's how that works so the steps
I'm going to highlight what changes in
greens for the steps the user still does
what they want to do connect my account
and then the client application is going
to calculate a long random value like
really long at least 43 random
characters like really long and it's
going to keep that value secret it's
going to be like ah I'm going to store
that value associated with this user so
I know who the user is I'm going to
store this value for now
and then
it's going to calculate the hash value
of that random string like a hash you
feed it through a hash and you get like
a unique value associated with the input
but you can't reverse a hash that's a
property of hashes you can't reverse
them so if I tell you a long hash value
you can't tell me what the input was you
can try to guess but you'll you'll have
to literally try a recalculate the hash
to see if it matches there's no way to
go back and we call the secret value we
call that a code verifier and the hash
of that we call that a code challenge
and we're going to send that hash to the
authorization server in the flow in Step
4 and 5 here so we're basically telling
the authorization server in the start we
know something
and we're going to give you proof that
we know it because we calculated
something on this value but we're not
telling you what the secret value is
we're just giving you the proof and the
authorization server will keep track of
that value alongside with the
authorization code that was created so
the authorization server now has an
authorization code and that hash like
somebody had a secret I don't know what
it was but we'll see we'll see any
client receives that authorization code
just like before and exchanges that
authorization code for tokens with
credentials and at that moment in step
then here we include our code verifier
our secrets the client says like you
know in the beginning I told you I had a
secret
for this specific interaction well
here's that secret
here's proof that I'm really the one
that started this in the beginning
here's proof that nobody else is messing
with this that the Integrity is
preserved because otherwise I wouldn't
have been able to tell you this very
long random string right now in Step 10
and that's essentially what happens and
the authorization server will be like
we'll see about that and it rehashes
that value and compares the hash to the
stored hash and if everything matches
then awesome this is valid and you get
your tokens and you are a happy client
because you can access the API and that
is essentially a best practice today for
every authorization code flow the use of
Pixie proof key for code exchange all
right the whole purpose was to initiate
through associate the initialization in
step four here with the finalization of
the flow in Step 10 with the code
exchange that's the goal of Pixie and
that is a current best practice in all
our security best practices and a lot
2.1 as well
all right
awesome what about
front-end web applications
well
if you
ever read the original spec in 2012.
you will have read that front-end web
applications use the implicit Grant and
then
things changed web applications
developed we got more
advanced in how we built them more
capabilities in the browser we were easy
to easily make API calls across Origins
and so on and today the best practice
for front-end web applications is to use
the authorization code flow
that is something that changed in March
2020 if I'm not mistaken and that kind
of caused some Shock waves to the
community because all of a sudden your
implicit flow is deprecated and you use
the authorization code flow for front
ends with Pixie by the way how does that
change well if you had the original back
end flow we had at step 10 which
required client credentials well guess
what you can't put client credentials in
a front-end Javascript app because evil
hackers will just open your JavaScript
files and be like oh that's your secret
or this or that and they just extract it
and abuse it and that's not very good so
that step it does not require client
credentials it cannot require client
credentials a front-end web app is what
we call a public client meaning it has
no Authentication
which may result in some issues down the
line but we'll talk about that in a bit
so this step is not authenticated and
all of the security relies on that
redirect URI that URI that you register
up front like when you're done you send
the authorization code to this endpoint
in step 9. this endpoint is now a
front-end web page that is being loaded
and the security relies on the attacker
not being able to intercept that because
if you want to change that to evil.com
the authorization server is like no
you're not allowed to do that I'm only
sending it back to app.restergrade.com
something something
well first thing of Page Apps index.html
is something something and JavaScript
was boot up or load will re retrieve or
read that value from the URL exchange it
for tokens um with that authorization
server and hopefully everything works
out that's essentially how front ends
work current best practice today awesome
awesome why because when I talk about
oau these days I don't have to talk
about a whole bunch of flows it's like
yeah authorization code flow with Pixie
done
you're probably thinking that's all
great but I'm a mobile developer like I
don't care about web apps well first of
all if you're a mobile developer your
life is probably a lot easier than if
you're a front-end web developer but
that aside how does this work in mobile
apps well
here's a scenario for front-end web apps
I'm going to highlight the changes for
mobile apps
pay close attention
that's it
is the authorization code flow with
Pixie so seriously my life building
slides is hard it's like copy the slide
right click the image change picture
with bam New Image and we're done that's
it I don't even have to draw these
because my wife does that for me so
that's awesome awesome as well
she has no idea what it means though but
I'm just saying like I need this icon
it's like okay I'll make it happen and
that's pretty cool seriously mobile
applications use the authorization code
flow with Pixie have been for a while by
the way I think I don't know the exact
date but it's like six six years that
they are supposed to do that and pixie
was originally invented for this flow
with mobile apps because of a potential
app-based interceptions like a malicious
app could intercept the authorization
code in Step 9 and because of that
exchange it and with Pixie that's no
longer possible and then they sell like
hey this pixie thing is actually pretty
awesome and it protects against a couple
of weird attacks like code injections
and that's why they require that for
every flow as well
now a side note for mobile apps in
mobile apps there's some interaction
with a browser and this may seem weird
you are supposed to do this in a browser
in mobile apps so the oauth specs
actually say that you're supposed to use
a system rust or another webview because
webviews are insecure as in if you're a
mobile app and you embed a webview in
your app you can actually reach into the
webview lower keystrokes and execute
additional code to whatever you want
basically so that's not a best practice
what you're supposed to do is use the
system browser which is on iOS and SF
Safari review controller if I'm not
mistaken and on Android a chrome custom
tabs and there you can integrate the
system browser style it a bit so you can
style whatever is around that but you
can't access the internals of the page
and that is the recommended best
practice gives you benefits as well
because that system browser has access
to existing sessions it's basically just
your normal
os's browser but just in an embedded
format if you have an active session
with Google for example you will be able
to reuse that session for single sign-on
across mobile apps things like that
absolutely highly recommended to do that
and that is the best practice for mobile
applications we use the embedded system
browser to run an oauth authorization
code flow with Pixie
I also know
that some of you are building mobile
apps you're like yeah this browser-based
thing usually it's like marketing
doesn't like it because it disrupts the
user experience and they want this
native login form and we just capture
credentials and we do some weird stuff
with credentials and by sending them
directly to the authorization server
that is never or nowhere recommended by
oat that's a violation of the oad specs
yes a lot of people are doing it yes a
lot of vendors support it for exactly
those reasons but no it's not legitimate
oad and it's not recommended one of the
downsides of doing that is that you're
teaching users to just enter credentials
whenever an app asks it so whenever a
mobile app is like yeah just give me
your Google credentials it's like what
no of course not
so that's a bit of a problem there are
cases where this does make sense but
it's not just no it's not recommended or
what and please don't call it oauth
because it really really isn't
all right
that brings us to an overview of oat
flows
in the original spec you found the
authorization code grand there are
called flows they're called grants I
don't know why you have the implicit
Grand you have the resource owner
password credentials Grant and you have
the client credentials Grant that's what
the oath spec in 2012 proposed and each
of these had a very specific use case in
mind and here's how it translates into
modern current best practices or 2.1
basically if you want to call it that
the authorization code Grant is still
there
every user-facing application is
supposed to use it but you have to
augment it with Pixie that is how it
changed you have to use pixie when you
want to be compliant with current best
practices all right
implicit Grand is deprecated out no
longer valid don't use it if you're
using it my advice is it's not really
more broken than it was two three years
ago and it's just there's a better
option authorization code flow so my
advice is start phasing it out as in put
it on a roadmap like yeah we probably
want to replace this with the
authorization code flow it's going to
work in a very similar way and libraries
all have support for that so it
shouldn't be that difficult
all right it's not something that means
you have to stand up now and run out to
fix your applications and change the
implicit Grant but it's something you
should think about doing in the next
let's say a couple of months
which I say every time I give the stock
so I you have some leeway there so
whatever then the resource owner
password credentials grant that was kind
of an abomination in the spec with good
intentions and then people are like yeah
let's abuse that thing so that one got
deprecated like really fast
um like a year or a couple of years
after the original spec so you shouldn't
be using that one and then the client
credentials Grant that's actually
preserved in 2.1 that's the only flow
that made it through the Whole Decade
without needing modifications it's also
the only flow that just like send a
request get a response done
kind of plays a role here I guess but
that's how things work in practice
awesome
don't run away yet there's more to come
because there's like a side flow a
supporting flow the refresh token flow
because you can get refresh tokens and
refresh tokens allow you to get a new
access token from the authorization
server in case you need one and the
refresh token flow
originally was only available for
backend web applications that could
authenticate as a client and things were
fairly straightforward and no
complications and everybody was happy
and awesome and then
things change because now front-end web
applications can also run a refresh
token flow because they run an
authorization code flow with Pixie they
can get a refresh token and they can run
a refresh token flow and that one
requires some changes and that brings us
to this part of the presentation
what's the problem here well with a
back-end application you had
authentication on the request to
exchange the refresh token for a new
access token good
front-end web apps no secret
meaning no Authentication
meaning refresh tokens in front-end web
apps have become Bearer tokens
and the properties of a bear token are
if you are the holder of the token you
have the authority to use it meaning if
you can steal a refresh token from a
front-end web app
well guess what you now have it so you
now have the authority to use it evil or
not that's what the bear token means and
that's exactly what the problem is here
in this flow so you use a refresh token
to get a new access token so you can
access the API skipping through a couple
of steps here and oauth 2.1 or the oads
best practices for browser-based apps
say like yeah these refresh tokens is
bear tokens they're not ideal so we have
to use a concept called
refresh token rotation so refresh tokens
enable short-lived access tokens good
but these are bare tokens and bear
tokens means they're really vulnerable
and because of that the specs say you
need to use refresh token rotation which
means you can see this in the image
right here let's see if I can highlight
that
um and see here we use a refresh token
and we get a new refresh token when we
get a response and that refresh token a
new refresh token that's something you
have to use the next time and the next
time and that's what refresh token
rotation is all right how does that what
does that look like on a timeline here's
a timeline from left to right like old
to new you kind of get how this works
right and the application obtains tokens
access token 1 and refresh token 1. and
let's say that access token 1 is valid
for 10 minutes which is a good practice
by the way if you can do that awesome
that means that after 10 minutes access
token 1 is going to expire and the app
will no longer have access to the API
but we have a refresh token and that
means that after nine minutes we can go
to the to the authorization server and
be like hey
we have a refresh token we would like a
new access token and the authorization
server will verify everything like oh
yeah that makes sense here's a new
access token 82 and by the way here's a
new refresh token rt2 for next time you
come around and again the access token
to solve for 10 minutes so we do the
dance again and in nine minutes we use
rt2 to get access token 3 and refresh
token 3 and then we do it for four and
so on and so on and you you kind of see
how this works in practice right
that's refresh token rotation
that's mandatory
for better refresh tokens
all right
now how does this make things better
well it's because there's a second step
in this whole process and that second
step comes into play when a refresh
token is reused because you're not
supposed to use a refresh token twice
you're always supposed to use the new
one and
the scenario looks as follow so the app
has legitimate refresh tokens until at
some point the attacker compromises the
front-end app
I'm going to use an attacker here so I'm
Anders he's a up front here Anders is
essentially
our attacker he breaks into an
application he threw cross a scripting
for example he steals a refresh token
from the app and ships it off to a
server somewhere and he can now abuse
that token he can use that token to
essentially obtain fresh access tokens
from the SDS that's a malicious behavior
here and the attacker is doing that
in practice meaning that the attacker
has access tokens in name of the user
allowing him to
access apis on behalf of the user and
what's worse the attacker also received
a refresh token so the attacker can now
use that refresh token with long-term
access however the front end doesn't
know that this happened the front end is
fully unaware of these attacks so the
front end is basically
going to use that refresh token at some
point in time and when that happens the
authorization server will detect that
authorization server will be like hold
on I saw this refresh token before why
are you using it a second time that
makes zero sense
and the security the authorization
server will see that as a violation
and it will revoke the entire refresh
token chain so it will rev it will not
issue a new token it will revoke
the refresh token tree that was issued
to the attacker to ensure that the
attacker no longer has access to that
token chain and to the API on behalf of
the user and that's refresh token
rotation that's essentially how that
works and that is
mandatory according to oauth's 2.0 best
practices in OA 2.1 for their refresh
tokens you can also have Center
constraint refresh tokens which are
basically refresh tokens that require
permissions to execute certain required
permissions require authentication to
exchange them for tokens which is used
by back-end web applications
all right awesome uh question time in a
room like this is like shouting really
hard and hoping I hear that
um it kind of worked out I kind of
understood the questions the question
was do refresh tokens have the same
lifetime of access tokens or different
lifetimes they whatever you want
basically as in they can have different
lifetimes usually a refresh token is
alive for longer so in a front-end web
app what would typically happen is you
would have an access token with like
five to ten minutes Lifetime and a
refresh token with something like 8 to
12 hours which kind of mimics a session
of the user that is something that is
not uncommon but you're fully in control
you can decide how that works in
practice
all right
if you have other questions it's
probably easier to grab me after the
talk to discuss that
um or run up front and Whisper it in my
ear that's also a good option
shouting is
maybe successful I don't know we can try
it again but I'm not sure if it's going
to succeed another time
refresh Docker rotation
this is where things get
challenging because the idea behind
refresh or the road token rotation is
that the attacker breaks into the app
executes malicious JavaScript steals a
refresh token and exit and basically
uses that refresh token to obtain tokens
and that perception of JavaScript that
perception of malicious JavaScript of a
Crosshair scripting attack in the front
end is somewhat mistaken
because it's it relies on the fact that
the attacker is basically a script Kitty
that doesn't really know what they're
doing it's like
able to access tokens mostly likely in
local storage I'm extracting those
tokens and abusing them immediately and
that is a simplistic not so
realistic attack so how does that work
well you execute that attack meaning you
as the attacker for example you write a
review and you add a snippet of
JavaScript code and if you visit that
application with that review that code
executes in your browser so if it's my
code if I'm the attacker I can now
execute that code in your browser I can
steal your refresh token send it to a
server that I control that's me at the
bottom and once I get that refresh token
I can use it and now I have tokens in
your name so I can access the API that
is the scenario that refresh token
rotation tries to protect against also
works with access tokens by the way I
can still access tokens and refresh
tokens and abuse both of them how would
you do that an attack like this is super
straightforward it looks like this you
load an image in that image you drop all
the data in the URL all the data from
local storage and you load it from an
evil server malicious food that's my
evil server I like food sorry about that
and we send it off to there and we can
abuse it
this is the attack scenario that refresh
token rotation addresses and
in essence that's why we have
short-lived access tokens because if you
steal an access token you can only abuse
it for five to ten minutes good and if
you seal a refresh token and you use
that well refresh token rotation the
authorization server will detect that
and will revoke tokens so the attack is
stopped and that's the whole idea behind
the security mechanisms and that ID is
completely flawed it doesn't work
because this is a very simplistic silly
attack it's not what a real attacker
would do script kiddies are not your
threat model yes it's good to keep them
out and to protect your applications
against script kitties but the real
attackers will not be stopped by these
security mechanisms
two scenarios where this doesn't work
very well one is
slightly more sophisticated attack
instead of just stealing a token and
using it what if we only use it
at a convenient time and it works like
this so we execute our attack as in I
create a review with the malicious
JavaScript it loads in your browser and
I the first thing I do in malicious code
is instead of just stealing the data I
send I set up a heartbeat like every 10
seconds I'm gonna call my own server
like hey
these browser is still online hey this
browser is online every 10 seconds like
here I am here I am here I am alright
step one step two is I'm gonna steal
your refresh tokens every time you get a
new refresh token I'm gonna stake it and
ship it off to my server just collecting
it like here is that latest refresh
token RT one two three four all the way
up to 17 or whatever until the heartbeat
dies until the heartbeat is no longer
there
well I'm gonna wait and if it's not
there 10 seconds later and 10 seconds
later guess what you are now offline you
have closed the tab in your browser you
have shut down your laptop you have lost
Wi-Fi connectivity I don't care what you
did but the app is no longer online
that's essentially step five we detected
the heartbeat has died and guess what
your app is not gonna do when it's
offline
well you don't have to guess because I
can't hear you anyway there's a lot of
noise back here from downstairs as well
but guess what the app is not going to
do use the latest refresh token because
it's not a fine anymore so the attacker
is now excellent all right the latest
one was rt17 perfect I'm going to use
rt17 with the authorization server I
will get access token 18 and refresh
token 18 and I can now pretend to be
well pretend to be you I can pretend to
be you for the next amount of time which
can often be hours until the refresh
token chain finally expires that's
essentially a very nasty attack factor
that fully
takes advantage of what refresh token
rotation has to offer it basically
sidesteps refresh token rotation and it
can't protect against attacks like this
that is a big problem
and the whole problem with cross-site
scripting and malicious JavaScript is
that the attacker controls the front-end
application they can do anything that
you as a front-end developer would be
able to do
and there's one worst thing the attacker
can do and this next scenario is
basically
not good it's even worse than
sidestepping refresh token rotation and
the next scenario is just getting a new
set of tokens we have the application
app.resquery.com doing its thing and you
know what front-end applications do when
you load them the first time
they don't have any state
because modern API modern sdks for
frontlands they don't store stuff in
local storage they hide tokens as good
as they can
to prevent them from being stolen by a
malicious attacker by an attacker
running JavaScript so they hide tokens
and God knows what places like web
workers good example of that worker we
hired a refresh token in the web worker
and you can't access that and that's
true there's no straightforward way or
there's no way to access the data in the
web worker awesome good
but
the attacker here is smart and what does
the app do when your first bootstrap it
that doesn't have a worker it doesn't
have state so it's going to run a hidden
iframe based flow like it's going to
load an iframe hide that frame in the
browser run a silent flow which will use
your existing session with the
authorization server if you have one
that's why you load the app and it's
unauthenticated in like a second later
flip it's like welcome Philip that means
the app has run that flow in the
background it's like oh there's a cookie
oh yeah the authorization server knows
that it's Philip from 10 minutes ago
awesome it's gonna automatically issue a
code which is exchanged for tokens and
fluke you are now authenticated single
sign-on at work and a lot of sdks do
this by default by the way the art zero
SDK if you just included for angular or
reactor view the first thing it does is
like let's see if there's a session and
token spam bam done
awesome
good the app does what it does we don't
care about that we're the attacker now
what do we as the attacker do well
we're gonna abuse the fact that there's
no authentication in this flow
the entire security of this flow relies
on that redirect URI like we only send
the code to app.prestroke.com and
nowhere else but guess what we as the
attacker control if I have that
malicious JavaScript in your browser
icontrolapp.restuate.com my code runs in
that specific
origin and I can do whatever I want
within app.resterway.com in your browser
so what am I going to do I'm going to
run that same pattern I'm going to load
a hidden iframe in an iframe I'm going
to bootstrap a hidden Asylum
authorization code flow which will send
a request to that authorization server
from your browser and it will include
your cookie
either your cookie was still there from
before or it's there because you
authenticated to the app your browser
has a cookie for the authorization
server and the authorization server will
know who you are it's like oh you want a
new set of tokens like sure it doesn't
know that this is malicious JavaScript
code for all it knows that you open a
new tab and went to restaurant.com again
and it's just a new instantiation of the
app there's no difference
once we get the authorization code we
can send it to the attacker's controlled
resource we can exchange that code for
tokens and that's a fresh set of tokens
now it's a set of tokens that is
unrelated to the legitimate applications
tokens
and it's completely new
and fully in control of the attacker now
and that's not good because the attacker
can now exchange that code for tokens
access token refresh token valid for 8
to 12 hours and we now have access in
name of the user for 8 to 12 hours and
that is a massive problem
and every front-end security scenario
that relies on trying to hide tokens
from the attacker is vulnerable to
attacks like this there's no good way to
protect against this because this is
inherent to the security model of
front-end web applications the moment
you control that you control it all and
you can do whatever you want
so I have a question if you're a friend
or developers or are you screwed
well the answer is kind of yes
in case you're wondering like absolutely
yes
all right if I would and I end here this
would be kind of depressing it's like ah
this is all messed up in all kinds of
ways good luck with that bye bye now
there is a solution
and the solution is actually what a lot
of high highly sensitive applications
are doing and the solution is don't
build front-end web applications which
is not very helpful right so the
solution is not don't build and the
solution is build them but move the
oauth components to a back end for
front-end pattern that's what you're
supposed to do and that's a back end for
front button here's the conceptual idea
so instead of the front end here which
is Direct in directly interacting with
the authorization server with the API
we're going to put a back-end component
a BFF in front of that and your
front-end and your BFF together that's
your application that's essentially the
front end
and for the rest nothing changes so all
you do is basically you add that BFF
becomes the oauth client application so
you move the O out features from the
front end into the BFF and you keep
track of that with a cookie that's it
just like that and what what does that
mean it means that the BFF becomes the
oath client which is interacting with
the authorization server and guess what
it backends web application does when it
interacts with the authorization server
it authenticates client credentials
whether it's secret based or key based
doesn't matter it authenticates whenever
it uses tokens and how does a front-end
column API well it just calls an
endpoint on the BFF BFF slash reviews
and the BFF will see that request and
it's like oh you want to call an API
endpoint awesome I'm going to take your
cookie I'm going to retrieve your tokens
as a user so if you make that request to
me as the BFF I'm going to take your
cookie retrieve your access token slap
your access token on the request and
send it to the actual API
and the API hasn't changed the API is
still your API from before it gets the
request with an access token it uses the
access token to make authorization
decisions and gives you a response and
the response goes back to the front end
that's the concept of a BFF
and the BFF here is nothing more than a
glorified proxy
it's very disrespectful to BFFs but it's
the truth it's a glorified proxy that
just four skulls it has no business
logic no authorization information no
API specific information it just knows
here's a cookie I can use that cookie to
get to tokens slap tokens on the request
and forward them and send a response
back that's what a BFF really does in
practice
you can build that BFF
in a stateful way or stateless way
whatever you want
you can put tokens in a cookie encrypt
that cookie and send it to the browser
that would be a secure way of
implementing that in practice
what's the benefit here well the benefit
is even if the attacker compromises this
it can't the attacker can't or exchange
code here for tokens
there's no silent flows
to execute because all of the flows that
you would execute require client
authentication on the code exchange
client on delegation on a refresh token
exchange making the whole security
approach a lot better
so the BFF allows you to follow best
practices for back-end web applications
makes it easier to use things like
sender constrained tokens backed by mtls
would be easy to implement on a BFF
would be a nightmare in front lens or
virtually impossible in web-based
front-ends
and I can hear you thinking like yeah
but
does that really solve cross-site
scripting no it doesn't
but it solves the consequences of
Crosshair scripting well not really it
it reduces the impact of the attack
let's call it that because CrossFit
scripting is always possible and my
first advice when we talk about this is
fix your damn cross-et scripting
problems because that's a real major
issue in a web app get that right on my
website I have a lot of advice on doing
that for a reactant angular by the way
so look at that
but the benefit here is the BFF never
exposes tokens to
an attacker there's no way for a
detector to obtain tokens from the
front-end alone and the only thing the
attacker can do is asked BFF to send a
request meaning that the BFF can choose
which endpoints to expose it's not full
raw API access it's limited through what
the BFF exposes to the front end and
second your BFF could implement
some normal sensible rules on what
you're supposed to do as a front-end if
your front end requests like
sense request 10 requests per minute in
normal cases well guess what if it sends
10 000 in a minute you might want to be
at the BFF level like me you've had
enough for now what the hell is wrong
with you that can definitely work as
well so this gives you the power to
control
and this actually makes the whole
scenario a hell of a lot better so
that's actually how things are improving
so BFS relying core building blocks
they're nothing special what they
basically do is they have the use of
cookies they use a back end over at
client library and that's it
again a glorified proxy if you're
familiar with do any identity server
they have a library a BFF library that
implements that whole BFF concept for
you and if you're not familiar there's
also a package from manfred's tire that
has an a reverse proxy that does
something very similar so you'll find
existing implementations of BFFs and
building that yourself is not going to
be a month worth of work it's going to
be a day two days and that's it and you
have a fully tested fully configurable
BFF you can use across all your
applications awesome and they can be
stateful stateless depending on what you
prefer as an implementation pattern
good what's the takeaway here the
takeaway is that oh outs 2.x because
it's it's an ongoing problem
underestimates the power of malicious
JavaScript
as in the security measures in oauth
will not protect you against full
compromise if you have a cross-eyed
scripting vulnerability be aware of that
because that is a very big limitation of
these specs
in the industry a best practice for
security sensitive applications
is to use BFFs instead of plain front
ends that have their own client ID the
BFF is the ORD client and this for
example very relevant here is used in
your Norwegian Healthcare System like I
know that people uh responsible for
building that from udelts they they were
at the conference as well they probably
still are and they know about these
problems and they feel like yeah screw
front ends no freaking way that we can
have a front end as a legitimate client
we only allow back-end clients or mobile
apps if I'm not mistaken I'm not exactly
sure and we enforce the use of a BFF for
front ends
all right
yes light again awesome the dark slides
hide you and then a light slide you're
like oh my eyes but uh
sorry about that usually it's not that
dark in the audience so what else is
there Beyond oi 2.1 like what else
um is there to look at like I said in
the beginning oh 2.1 can't incorporate
everything that they would have wanted
because otherwise it's going to be a
nightmare to get to supporting or 2.1 if
you're like yeah you're all that stuff
two one zero plus these five additional
things are gonna be like yeah screw it I
will stay on OA 2.0 for a while
Twitter's still a lot a lot one uh for
example so yeah that happens in practice
so they said like oh 2.1 is simple
straightforward if you're doing over 2.0
right you are doing or 2.1 get there
today that's something I can highly
recommend get this thing these things
sorted out make sure you do that
correctly and then if you want more
there's more security conscious
configurations of all art where you have
things like jar where you have the
authorization initialization URI with
all the parameters that's now a Json web
token you can push that to the
authorization server before sending it
that's bar pushed authorization requests
you have RAR for Rich authorization
requests where you can ask like
fine-grained consent from the user for
for example for financial transactions
you can ask consent for a single
transaction with all the parameters
that's RAR and then fappy2
is for the Fortified apis highly
security sensitive configurations on
what to do right for example for
financial apis or Healthcare apis
just a couple of references you can dig
into these yourself if you're interested
in going beyond the current best
practices and improving the security of
your deployment all right brings us to
three important key takeaways number one
you should probably be able to say this
together with me but number one if you
use or 2.0 the right way which you
should you're already doing or 2.1 that
should be a relief it's like oh awesome
if you're not
look into improving that because these
things are really really important
things like pixie are important
so make sure you start using that as
soon as you can
use your applications instead of having
all of these different flows it's like
the optimization code flow at pixie and
that's it frontland web app mobile web
app backend web app all the same flow
makes my life as a teacher a lot easier
because I don't have to explain all of
these different flows with different
trade-offs and so on and a lot of these
things translate into oidc as well maybe
not officially but in practice and IDC
flow will support something like pixie
if the authorization server does that
awesome
and then third security sends the
front-end web apps they can't stand on
their own in an oath ecosystem you
really really have to look into that BFF
pattern it's the only proper way to make
sure you can protect your applications
in the front end and those are the three
most important takeaways
if some of these things are like Chinese
or I don't know if you're in Norwegian
Dutch to you whatever a language you
don't really understand which for me is
a lot of languages starts with French
which Belgian people don't like if you
don't speak French but sure um I have a
course a lot it's about oau 2.0 but I
cover a lot of best practices so you can
scratch it out and write 2.1 it's going
to be sort of similar so check it out if
you want to thank you very much for
being here um I'm gonna stick around
after the session so you can ask me
questions if you have any
um we're not going to do it live because
it's going to be a nightmare with the
the height and the shouting and the
noise and stuff like that so ask me
afterwards and connect with me on social
media if you want to stay in touch and
stay up to date on security thank you
very much